[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your mind
open phones at
225 Ariana Is With Us in Portland Oregon
to start off this hour hi Ariana how are
you good how are you better than I
deserve what's up I am trying to figure
out how I can get my husband on the same
page with his outof control spending so
that we can have an emergency fund to
fall on
and pay off some of our debts that we
have well what is this out of control
spending what do you mean my husband
spends over ,000 a month just on phone
games oh phone games like Candy Crush
yeah on his
iPhone oh
wow yes and it's um I found out look at
our
statements yeah when you say that out
loud does it sound as crazy to you as it
does to me yes like this is this is this
is like illness level I'm uh last year
he I'm sorry you cut out honey what' you
say uhoh thousand you're cutting in and
out you he spent what 14,000 last year
yeah and what what's your household
income
apparently your phone has not been paid
um I can't we're losing most of your
phone here so okay so uh what is your
household income 83 $83,000 okay are you
somewhere where you can walk and get a
better signal maybe um because we're
losing you about every third word all
right $85,000 how old is your
husband 29 okay all right um I have a
question have a four-year-old daughter I
I have a question it's just what I'm
wondering something tells me this is not
the only thing he's over spending on
what else is he spending crazy money
on um his car his his what his car his
car car what's that yeah he has a 91
Volkswagen yeah okay which yeah just
that just screams money right there um I
a stay-at-home mom yeah and
I am the one that pays the bills yeah
and I
pinch money wherever I can okay um so
that we can get those paid you're you
you guys need to see you need to get
some professional help that's what I'm
thinking too yeah because this is not
$100 uh and he makes
$200,000 and it's over a, I know I know
it's 14,000 a year and the money we're
spending on the car too so there's
something I'm sure you're aware of this
or maybe you haven't heard but in in
dealing with our phones what we are now
discovering is that a lot of the things
the games and the games have actually
have them they've carefully designed the
games to create a dopamine hit to cause
you to come back again and again and
again they designed these games to be
addictive if if you're not aware of that
that's it's very true okay it's also
true of for instance the way the videos
now work on slot machines they have
carefully designed those to be addictive
and uh so your husband is involved in an
addictive behavior Loop because if you
just say what he's doing out loud
everyone that hears it except him thinks
cray cray yes they think he's nuts I
know okay and so this is not a money
problem this is you have a husband that
is addicted problem now what do you do
with that if your husband was doing
cocaine if your husband was doing
pornography if your husband was doing
some other form of addiction what would
you do well you would
demand that he gets some help and you
would begin to see someone to build
language and a narrative to talk to him
in such a way that he starts to
understand that he's destroying himself
and his family with this
Behavior yes because I feel like at this
point I'm him this point what it feels
like I'm talking at him oh yeah you are
you're talking to an adct I just feel
like I'm nagging he's glazed over you're
talking to him when he's drunk yeah you
can't talk to a drunk right it doesn't
make any sense and so but you what you
do need to do is sit down with someone
that can give you some language that
says okay this is terrifying me I have a
baby and I feel like I am in the house
with a cocaine
addict right because you are exhibiting
the exact same behaviors as a cocaine
addict yes and he just spent 700 in the
last three days yeah oh so it's getting
worse my goodness well I mean we've
established he's out of control we don't
need any more we don't need any more
evidence that's established does he
think that there's a problem at all or
when you bring it up is he like no this
is fine this is there's no problem here
he's told me twice that he was going to
disconnect the car from his phone but
then that did not happen yeah well I
mean I'm I promise you I'm not going to
get drunk anymore but I am hanging out
in the bar right yeah right and we do
have a car payment every month and with
what he spent last year we could have
paid off the full balance of what we owe
left yeah but we the car payment is not
your problem the problem is your your
husband is an addict yes and you need to
start treating the situation like your
hair is on fire okay with lots of
urgency and so are you guys by chance in
a good
church um no we're not who is in his
life that can talk to him that will
listen to him it's not you it's
definitely not me
um I have I think that we'd have to hire
somebody that doesn't know us because he
doesn't have a father figure or a mother
that he'll listen to so you you need to
you need to say honey I'm going to
marriage counseling because I'm afraid
our marriage is going to end because I'm
terrified that I'm married to an addict
you are completely out of control I'm
going to go see a marriage counselor to
try to save our marriage I hope you'll
come okay and set an appointment and go
okay regardless of whether he goes or
not you go without him okay and have
that person start to teach you how to
speak to an addict to give you any
possibility of getting through the fog
of this into his brain and he remembers
that he's a husband and a father more
than he is a game player on a freaking
iPhone right I think he defies it
because he works so much I don't care
how much he works it doesn't mean you
don't just because you work a lot
doesn't mean you get to do cocaine oh
think sorry that's not how this works I
think not trade off here I think if I
were in her shoes his phone would
suddenly go missing tonight you think it
would just look at you it's almost like
it ended up in the river and no one
knows how it got there I have no idea
where it is you know after I dropped it
out of the car doing 95 I have no idea
what happened to that F exactly it's
somewhere between one of those mile
markers back there
no idea but he'll have another one by
morning if he's not well that's true
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show well you've all played the
telephone game the first person Whispers
a message to the second person who
Whispers it to the third and so on
around the table until the original
message has completely changed multiply
that confusion by a 100 if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of ramsy we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we use to optimize and take
us to the next level netsuite gave us
the visibility into all of our numbers
so that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with us netw week
worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
8825 5225 Josh is in Indianapolis hey
Josh how are
you good Mr Ramsey how are you doing
better than I deserve what's
up so my wife and I are planning on
making a baby soon and question is how
much money should we have saved up for
our future before doing
that well at the very least I would say
if you're on the baby steps whatever
baby step that you're on I would pause
that and then whatever money that you
can stack up stack up as much money as
you possibly can and then once the baby
is born you can take that money and
throw it on whatever baby step you're on
what baby step are you on
well so we have no debt we're I'm 21
she's 20 um we've been married we've
been married for almost a year now uh we
have 88500 in a cash emergency fund so
that's about three months of our uh
fixed expenses and then beyond that we
have just about seven Grand in the bank
um and two paid off used cars what's the
other Seven Grand for what was that
earmarked for well so we have that sort
of earmarked in three different buckets
we have a birthing fund we are going to
have a fully funded birthing fund of
about 5,000 that's the goal is that like
you're
deductible um so we're planning on doing
sort of the at home birth which uh some
of it will be covered not all of it um
so there's that uh so we have we have
that bucket we have a uh beginning of a
Roth IRA uh
uh that's another bucket and then we
have
down payment for a house bucket Josh few
humans few humans in the history of
mankind are as ready to have a child
financially as you are is she even
pregnant
yet no no we were thinking we have so
Dave I have we had a we had a plan that
I got okayed by both the dads my dad and
her dad I wanted to see if Uncle Dave
would approve of this plan and if you
would make any tweaks to it I would make
some
tweaks the the the prerequisites
financially was uh it's a total of 28
Grand uh 15 grand in house and
Investments uh savings uh five grand for
a burning fund and then the
8500 uh emergency fund let me make some
tweaks do you
mind yeah go for it all right so you're
she's not pregnant yet so let's let's
wait until she's pregnant to pause but
you've got money laying around here so I
like the 8500 that's your 3 months um is
she planning on working after the baby
is born
born yeah she'll have six weeks PTO we
have a a grandma and a mom on her side
they're both sort of on our way to work
okay so she does plan on going back to
work she does yeah okay so you've got
the $7,000 here uh whether or not you
want to keep that for your home down
payment fund I actually think that's the
best place for it you mentioned that
some of it was supposed to go into a
Roth
IRA yeah I've been in talks with
smartvestor Pro people and Edward Jones
uh interviewing all sorts of people
trying to see who could manage the money
the best the minimum it seems to be is
5,000 to get it into one of these at
least uh guided account management you
know accounts so that's kind of the goal
there so your goal is to say for baby
step 3 being and do baby step four
investing 15% at the same at the same
time yeah yeah we're saing for down
payment and would like to start
investing okay sort of and then also you
know how much money just in general
should we have playing around before uh
putting a kid in this world yeah you're
good yeah I I I think so too I mean once
she gets pregnant I like that you have
some of this money set aside for baby
step 3B and investing and if you wanted
to save up your deductible once she gets
pregnant I'm not mad at that either
Dustin's in Salt Lake City Utah hi
Dustin welcome to the Ramsey Show hi
thanks for having me sure um yeah so uh
about six years ago I received some uh
Company stock on loan uh that I would be
able to pay off in the next in the the
previous six years and it's coming due
and I'm I'm I'm a little bit unsure if I
should uh have the have them take the
stock back or if I should pay off the
loan that's a very unusual transaction
are you sure you don't have options to
buy the
stock well I was given options to buy
the stock uh probably about 11 years ago
and then at the end of those those was
it expired in five years and at the end
of the five years I said I don't have
$30,000 but I'd love to be a member or
part owner of the company at that at
that time so you borrow $30,000 from who
from the company oh
oh who own do you're well no you're
obviously not the owner of the company
okay uh oh definitely um um I mean can
you not sell the
stock it's it's privately owned it's a
yeah so I I can't go so have you have
you been paying payments or interest on
the
30,000 yeah I've been paying uh about
$600 a year what happens if you give up
the stock to the money you've paid
in um they just just they just keep it
take it back so you're you're going to
lose money on the
transaction uh yeah they i' I've gone
back and talked to them they said well
maybe this maybe that maybe they'll you
know give me stock to the the amount of
the interest I paid but nothing's
definite at this point how much has the
stock grown since
you've borrowed to get it um it has gone
up
from um 66 cents a stock to
$220 a share but you can't do anything
with it because it's privately held and
it's
restricted right so it has no value at
all to you except the cash that it
creates have they been paying you
dividends out on it while you were the
owner of it borrowed against uh no no
dividends has it paid dividends to the
other
stockholders uh no not that I know of
okay I'm turning it
in yeah here here's situation you have
zero control over this whether it makes
money or doesn't make money you can't
sell it ever except back to the company
it's a restricted privately held company
it does not have a a public Exchange to
it um and you have absolutely no control
over its value none whatsoever so I you
know if they want to give me some stock
oh sure I'll take that I mean a free
gift of anything I'll just about take as
long as it's moral but the uh um but the
but investing in this you're a minority
shareholder you have zero power to tell
anybody what to do with anything you're
at their Mercy at the mercy of the
handful of people that make the decision
whether this goes up in value due to the
way we run the company and make the
decision as to whether there's any
dividend distribution or not and so um I
I don't want to own any of that
personally so uh and I'm certainly not
going to pay for the opportunity
to sort of Own It by borrowing it no I
think we'll just let them have it back
man it's what I would do I have a
question about this what did he because
based on everything you're saying this
sounds horrible what did he think he was
getting because if if he buys it let's
let's pretend he didn't borrow the money
let's just say he bought into it and
there's no dividends paying out there's
no what did he think he was going to get
well the company
um they set the stock price MH it's not
set by the marketplace because there is
no Marketplace for it because it's not
publicly and so what you when you own a
company that's privately held um you you
you think the company's going to be
successful and so the value of the stock
the stated value went from 66 cents to
$2 or something so if he had actually
owned it and could sell it for the
triple it went up triple 30,000 would
have become
90,000 right but but but he has to have
a place to sell it and they that's my
question and if you get ready to sell it
you can't sell it on your schedule you
have to sell it on when they're willing
to buy it back and do so they got to
give him they got to be willing to hand
him $90,000 to take his ownership
portion away from him which is the stock
so it's just it it you don't have um any
flexibility with this right and let's
say he wanted to leave the company but
he had all this company stock they would
buy him out they would buy him out so
they would have to at that point pointy
up the9 because they're not going to let
a non-employee be walking around with
this privately held stock in most cases
anyway yeah it depends on I don't know
his exact situation but that's most of
those things are very it's tightly
closely held that's what they call it
privately held closely held
and so
um what he was hoping was to ride the
value up as the value of the as the
company becomes more successful and cash
out someday someday and but but the day
you don't have control over is the
problem and you don't have control over
how much it goes up in value cuz the
company could actually grow a lot and
the stock price not go up that could
happen interesting this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you 3 months free to get
started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from script
scripture readings and prayers to
journaling Hall makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember halow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com Ramsey today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hall.com
Ramsey
[Music]
thanks for joining us America this is
the Ramsey Show Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today if
you're joining us live from anywhere in
America you're joining us on Halloween
Boo the national retail Federation
believes Americans will continue
spending this holiday season despite
inflation and uh they have proven it
Halloween alone is expected to reel in
12.2
billion with the average participant
spending
$18.24 this marks the a $2 billion jump
compared to last year for Halloween
frightening 2 billion that is
frightening Bo Americans are expected to
spend 4.1 billion on costumes alone wow
pet costumes have become a recent Trend
that real talers are capitalizing on pet
owners are expected to spend around 700
million on dressing up their
pets
um I'm a
G I just I can't get mine it's it's not
good it's a
catastrophe what do you think about
that guys in the booth like that one
catastrophe okay that's why you get the
big bucks well here's the thing it says
there are countries with lower gdps than
12.2 billion so we spend more on
Halloween than some countries even spin
to just be there yeah listen I'm not
buying my Peta costume if you want to
buy your Peta costume that's okay but
let me tell you what you shouldn't be
doing
okay you should not be buying your pet
or yourself a
costume if you're whining about student
loan forgiveness uhoh you should not be
buying your pet or
yourself a costume if you've not been
generous and given more than that amount
away to someone a human being that's in
need like a hungry child Wow versus your
shihu with a two too I'm glad you said
Shih
Tzu I'm just saying unbelievable yeah I
me it's okay if you want to dress your
pet up but if your generosity factor is
lower than your personal costume
combined with your pet costume you have
issues if you're broke and your kid is
taking out a student loan because you
don't have any money and they're going
to
college but your labador retriever
or Worse your golden
doodle
is all doodled up yeah
then I mean again it it's not the issue
is not actually the actual spending the
issue is what you're not doing while
you're spending this yeah that would
drive that's that's you know in a
country where all we hear about is oh
all this drama about how house prices
are so high you Boomer don't understand
you were able to buy a house for
$13 and now you don't understand you're
you're right we don't understand why
you're dressing up your golden doodle
for Halloween we don't understand you're
right we we think you're nuts that's
true look where I come from if you had a
roll of foil and the old like a couple
of old toilet paper rolls you can make a
costume well I'm hey I like a party and
you know I'm pretty much into candy and
free candy coming from other people I
like the progam the program is a good
program I like the program but if
inflation is your problem if you're
worried about living paycheck to
paycheck you can't sit around and whine
about wealth
inequality when we spent $4.1 billion do
on costumes but Americans are the poor
is getting poorer and the rich is
getting richer and oh my God and know
you just can't have these both these
things coming out of your mouth it makes
you look stupid yeah it makes you look
as stupid as you are when you do that
stuff so it's okay celebrate Halloween
celebrate Christmas celebrate your pets
spend money on your pets I don't care
but then don't tell me that there's
hungry children in your neighborhood or
within 25 miles of where you're sitting
right now and you haven't done something
about feeding them that's very good
that's just wrong I mean we live in the
wealthiest Nation the world is ever
known in terms of total dollars and and
we prove it with
this these kinds of numbers so I I
really am not the Grinch I'm not against
Christmas and I guess the Grinch was
probably for Halloween I don't know how
I don't know I don't know his exact
stance on Halloween I haven't checked
the Grinch on Halloween but he's
probably Pro Halloween yeah he's
probably Pro Halloween but um you know
either way I'm not I'm not against all
this I know I'm not against fun I like
fun Fun's a good thing but you shouldn't
do it at the expense of the things that
should be a priority and you can't do it
while you're whining and complaining
about about the world to an end because
it's so unfair out there while I'm
running around chasing my own stupid
tail and you certainly shouldn't be
putting it on credit cards cuz I know
some of y'all went over to Home Depot
and those big giant skeletons that I see
in everybody's yard and those tombstones
cool they're giant they're amazing but
they're like 500 bucks a pop yeah my my
grandkids saw that the other day Papa
Dave you got to get one of those I
didn't but they told me I got to get one
Papa Dave you didn't get one Papa Dave
didn't get one so expensive it's just
I'm it's not that I you know I'm not
against large skeletons I'm perfectly
good if you're a large skeleton you're
on my team I'm just saying I'm I'm I'm
for you I'm for the large skeleton the
the large skeleton Union and Dave we're
in good shape I'm I support the union
but the uh oh my gosh y'all seriously
12.2 B
billion billion it's a lot that's a
thousand million a billion it's Rec
spending million oh it is record
spending in one of the worst econ eies I
mean the economy this time last year was
Boom Town compared to right now well you
know what that's an interesting thing
Dave because you ever go out to dinner
and it's like a Tuesday night and it's
not you can't get in a restaurant it's
totally full can't get in a restaurant
I'm like is this a myth because when I
go to Home Depot people are buying the
skeletons and when I go to dinner it's
packed full in there it's the uh it's
the Walmart measure of the economy if
the economy is horrible but the Walmart
parking lot is full something's wrong
with your measure oo you know so um cuz
you know Walmart customers are not
usually known as the same customer as
Nordstrom that's so if the Walmart
people are out there spending uh that
tells you the economy is probably not as
bad as somebody saying it is so I I I
think the economy is very slow right now
I think it's very sluggish we got these
ridiculous High interest rates on uh
houses right now um so let's uh dress up
like a kid and have a party yeah I guess
that's the plan it's kind of like during
uh the fouchy pandemic when the uh booze
sales oh yeah they went Wine and Booze
sales went through the roof the liquor
stores racked up I mean very few people
made more during the fouchy pandemic uh
than the liquor stores except the
plexiglass people well it really goes to
show the plexiglass people cashed in now
people will figure out a way to cope
with whatever it is obviously in Co
people did wine and beers and things
like that that's what it is we traded
one mask for another yeah oh who okay
that's what it is that's profound Dave
who knew so we got used to covering our
faces that's what it is that's profound
so you know so increase of $2 billion in
Halloween spending this year interesting
rent interesting discussion interesting
it just you know the thing is all we
want you to do on all of these things is
think I know it's a strain but put down
your phone and
think think because if you in one breath
are saying how horrible the world is and
in another breath are spending $800 for
a giant skeleton in your front
yard something's off in your little deal
right there baby you you need to think
you need to think this through and so
taking care of your kids taking care of
your adult
responsibilities and having a party can
all happen at the same time there is not
a problem with that got no issue with
that at all but you can't just you can't
have it both ways not not and look
intelligent I mean you look you look
foolish when you try to do it both ways
it just it doesn't play through for you
so consumers will be shopping early for
festive decor and other related items
retailers are prepared with the
inventory to help customers and their
families take part in this popular and
fun devil worship I mean tradition you
sounded like my
parents it couldn't could resist
couldn't resist it made it too easy it's
an underhand pitch it was yeah this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blind .c for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
Jade was all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Kyle is in Nashville hi
Kyle welcome to the Ramsey Show hey Dave
it's an honor to talk to you you too man
what's up so I have two questions today
one is a little bit more straightforward
the other one probably a little bit more
complex so uh the short one is so I'm 29
I have a sth Monon old baby and I have
another baby coming in May yay which is
very exciting yes but with that I'm
struggling to figure out given that and
also being an entrepreneur like should I
I feel like I should have more than six
months emergency fund saved so I'm
trying to figure out what's the right
number there and I'm kind of feeling
like no matter where I get it to I feel
like it's not enough so I'm curious why
what
event in your mind could occur or would
occur that would require more than 6
months of your expenses to be
covered you know that's an entrepreneur
I feel like I'm always thinking worst
case scenarios I'm like if there's a big
recession or who knows if all of our
business goes what is the likelihood
you're going to go six months with zero
income probably pretty unlikely yeah
like because as an entrepreneur you
would like get a
job true before that happened right yes
sir
or you start you close that business
start another one I don't know but I've
never I've been an entrepreneur my whole
life I've never gone six months without
an income I've never gone a month
without an
income yeah and I've been through some
pretty catastrophic bull crap but I
still didn't go without an
income what do you do what's your
self-employed work what do you do uh I
have a video production firm does your
does your business have
savings it does we have we try to keep
three months of uh run way on hand in
cash yeah then I think you're good I
think if you have your six months how
old are you I am 29 29 with a
seven-month-old and a baby on the way
yes sir you know what you are you're a
good
dad that's what you are no you're a good
dad that's why you're thinking about
this cuz you're concerned about taking
care of your babies M that's what's
making you think about this so but your
math is is fine but the fact that you're
worried about this just all that means
it doesn't mean your system's broken all
that means is you're a good man you just
looked around and went I've got
responsibilities and I need to act like
it so you're good you're good okay
awesome and so with that if I have extra
in my current emergency fund should I
reallocate that towards something else
put into Investments put on the mortgage
or dist it's not it's not going to kill
you what kills you is the
concept okay let's say you had 7 months
instead of 6 months and and you didn't
reallocate it that's not going to keep
you from becoming a millionaire you
understand but continually adding to
that and looking up there's
$107,000 in there because you
continually haven't dealt intellectually
with this emotional
concern then yeah then then you've
gotten yourself over into stupid land at
that point right yes well I feel like uh
I am in stupid land because that's
exactly how much I have in my f right
now
107,000 I have in a high yields account
but yeah I'm like hold on on oh wow in
what planet is a
$100,000 six months of your
expenses uh it's not we I was I was
shooting for a year and I justified by
saying hey well I'm self-employed my
wife's only working part-time now so I
should have more than the normal person
so what planet is
50,000 6 months of
expenses you have $10,000 a month of
expenses
well that kind of leads into my next
question on whether or not my wife and I
need to downsize our house but how much
is your house pay house payment is 4,200
okay what's your household yeah okay
then 50,000 would be there okay huh all
right yep and so with that what do you
make a
year so uh with bonuses uh take-home is
between like 300 no honey you own the
company what's your taxable income
that's it it's what so my my personal
take-home pay combined with my wife um
like what our takehome after taxes is
300 to 350 a year way to go okay all
right then I I you know maybe 100's not
too much if if 100 represents 6 months
of expenses and you have 48,000 is well
that's annualized no you have 24,000 is
your house payment for 6 months M yeah
so50 50 or 60 Grand probably enough yeah
that the point is you can't keep doing
what you're doing and add you can't make
100 into 200 into 300 into 400 in
savings and and high yield savings that
doesn't make it smart high yield savings
isn't even keep it up with inflation so
I mean you got Biden inflation at 9%
high yield savings paying four or five
so you're running backwards on every one
of those dollars are you investing at
all I am yes I've started doing 15% yeah
yeah and you got a house payment so I'm
I'm going to I'm going to take 40,000 or
30,000 of that I'm going to decide 60 or
70 is my emergency fund anything beyond
that I'm going to throw it at the house
and I'm going to start throwing
everything at the house from now on
Beyond 15% following the baby steps
exactly so yeah your income was a little
skewed more than I thought for some
reason I I had a more normal income in
my head but you're making a lot of money
he's doing good you're doing really good
doing so well yeah you don't really do
but yeah the the point is a a tiny bit
more or less of something is not what's
going to kill you it's the concept
that'll kill you if you extrapolate it
you know and extend it out into the into
Oblivion Caroline is with us in Chicago
hi Caroline how are
you good thanks for taking my call sure
what's up so I am about my lease on my
car is going to be up in a couple of
months yay and uh and I don't haven't
listened to your show a whole lot I'm
you've probably covered this but um I'm
64 right around the same time my lease
is up I will you know turn 65 go on
Medicare um I'm semi-retired I have a
little business I run out of my home but
so I'm trying to decide I have this is
my fourth lease in a row what's your
what's your net
worth
um I'm not sure how much do you have in
savings
Investments Investments and savings and
retirement I've got about
175 in
Investments um in
cash um I've probably hang on let me
look at my stuff here I mean in cash I
have e 50 to 60,000 in cash you you have
any other
Investments um like like retirement
Investments or 401k or Roth IR something
like that you're not telling me about
yet yeah I mean that's part of the 175
I've got so if we cash if we cashed you
out you're you got 200
Grand my house is paid off what's it
worth um
375 okay all right so Caroline let me
give you a couple of guidelines since
you're not a normal listener okay okay a
car lease we call them car
fleeces because they're the most
expensive way to operate a vehicle you
basically are borrowing the money at an
average of 14% interest that's what they
kind 14.2% is the average capitalization
on the American Carly all right okay and
so if you backed if you backed into the
actual interest that you're paying back
and you can back it out of the numbers
if you know how to run the numbers on
this that you're going to find you know
10 to 20% interest somewhere in there is
what you're paying the average
nationally is 14 .2 so Consumer Reports
many other people have documented that
the car lease is the most expensive way
to operate a vehicle never lease a car
okay rule number two never invest in a
brand new vehicle unless you've got a
net worth in excess of a million dollars
and the reason is that new vehicles go
down faster in value you lose more money
and you don't have the money to lose and
in your case you don't have the money to
lose you're 65 years old you've got a
paid for home you got $200,000 to your
name you don't have $2 million to your
name and so you don't need to turn a
$50,000 car into a $10,000 car over the
next 6 years which is what's going to
happen if you're driving one so buy a
one or a 2-year-old used car and pay
cash for it for the rest of your life
unless you inherit some money or get
some money and end up with over a
million dollar net worth do not buy new
cars folks you can't afford the
loss and and you certainly can't afford
to lease them and get
fleeced it's the most expensive way to
operate a vehicle drive a one or a twoy
old car perfectly fine and pay cash for
them this is the Ramsey
[Music]
sh
live from the headquarters of ramsy
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today the
phone number is8 825
5225 Justin is in Houston Texas hi
Justin how are you good afternoon Dave
good afternoon Jade are you doing good
today we're great how can we help
well um I'm I'm calling today about my
cousin Brandy um when you're when you're
an only child your cousins are like your
de facto siblings and my cousin Brand's
only L three weeks younger than me so we
often joke that we're the closest things
our families have to twins we grew up
very close and she has two kids right
now a 13-year-old son and a 5-year-old
daughter about two years ago um her son
Brandon wanted to start making his own
money because they live pretty poor they
he only makes about 18 or 19k a year and
he wanted some money because he wants to
go he's a he's a Astros fan he wants to
go to games he wants a jersey and he
wants to work and make his own money and
he Bor he actually handw wrotes letters
and there's this neighborhood next to
the apartment they live in he went
around Distributing these handwritten
letters hey I'll mow you along for $40
give me a call and he started getting
calls he borrowed my lawnmower for a
while started making his own money he
bought his own and even looked up
YouTube videos on how to take care of it
how oil and take care of the blades and
I was so proud of them so proud of them
for taking this initiative cool well a
little while later the money he had in
his drawer from working his mom took it
saying well no what do you mean I didn't
know you had this much money we got
bills to pay and and about and and so
much so he started hiding what he was
making yeah about a year about a year
ago he actually had enough save to buy a
riding lawnmower he bought it from a
pawn shop for about $900 again I'm
thrilled with them he's looking YouTube
videos taking care of it how to maintain
it and he brought my flatbed trailer
just so he could keep it at the house so
that way whenever he had a client I
would help him out in the weekends I
would just go over there hook and book
and so Mom is going in there Mom is
going in there and taking his hard
earned 10 15
bucks I'm afraid it's worse than that
Jade how much is he
making matter it doesn't matter the fact
that
she um about weeks ago he came home from
school and the mower's gone she sold it
saying that quote we needed to pay
bills um she sold her for $500 and this
so she's making she's making like you
said 18 or 19,000 a year is that what
you said yes
what's he's devastated she works as a
hotel desk clerk but it's not at a fany
hotel it's like one of these mom and pop
things only side of Houston and at this
point whenever he comes home is mower
gone he's crushed he's devastated I go
over there because I'm that close to
them I care about him I want to find out
what's going on all she tells me is that
we need to pay bills I need $500 so
sorry I had to tell some and she's
Unapologetic about it and at this point
she he's crying right there his eyes are
like Cherry he's devastated he just
stands up walks to her and says I can't
be your son because you're not a mother
right now you're a monster and storm
doph he he might have thrown in a for
word or to which I'm not just to stay on
radio and at this point so you're
standing there witnessing all this to
this lady who's like your sister and you
said what to
her at this point I was trying to say
why would you steal from him what are
you doing and she said two things one
you can't steal from your kid everything
that his is mine I needed to do
something that's what was available I
had to do what I had to do and then the
second of all was and I swear this is a
very small defense for her that is how
we were raised that's how our moms
raised up us and that's how our
grandmother raised them was whenever you
start working you pitch in and there's
no age requirement when I I got my first
job at 15 the first thing my mom wanted
to know is okay when are you getting
paid we got this bill to pay yeah and
and we were talk not to question it so
really I don't know what did to tell
them I don't know what the quote Ramsey
solution is on kids working trying to
earn their own money should they pitch
in or is their money there I'm just I'm
not low of to words because I don't have
kids
myself there a little I'm a little I
don't know what to tell her at this
point I care more about their Rel I
don't think she cares what you think
yeah I don't think she does either I
know she doesn't care what I think I
mean what she part of I think she blames
me for this part of because I'm I'm
appar she thinks I'm instilling ideas in
his head that he doesn't have to pitch
in that he gets to keep all theone to
what she's saying is like this has been
a generational thing this is the way
she's been raised it's the way you've
been raised your grandparents have been
raised and she thinks it sounds like she
thinks that this is right and like Dave
said I don't think she cares what you
think um at all like she thinks that
this is the best way to go uh obviously
I can look at the situation and see many
many things wrong with it a she's not
earning enough money she's it sounds
like an able-bodied healthy woman who
could go out and earn more than $18 or
$19,000 a year so it sounds like double
this next week
yeah yeah working 40 hours at Target she
could earn more yeah so um I mean run
over to run over to Walmart they're
paying 20 bucks an hour it's a lot more
than she's making now and she could work
60 hours a week before I take money from
my own kid MH so she has character
issues you can blame it on your family
tree if you want to but just because um
misbehavior is part of your family
heritage doesn't mean that it's a good
thing that doesn't make it okay if
anything I think it would make you want
to do better and do differently for your
kids yeah I mean there's a lot of a lot
of most of us have something somewhere
in our family history that we absolutely
don't want repeated yeah down the down
the family tree right so uh that's a
character character flaw including
stealing from a 13-year-old now if you
want to go down the path she's going
down philosophically you can go down
that path but it requires more courage
than being a thief it requires just
sitting down with a 13-year-old and go
hey we don't have much money we want you
to pitch in and so if you if we can you
know some of the money you make you
ought to pitch in here in the family and
demand that of him you could do that but
that's different than stealing out of
his underwear drawer or selling his
lawnmower when he's not home yeah that's
cowardly she did that because she knows
she's
wrong I'd probably bring that up if it
were if if it were my brother or sister
I'm really trying to put myself in your
shoes if it were my brother or sister
and saw that I think that I would
approach it in that way like what Dave
said I'd say look if you need help
around the family which by the way you
shouldn't but if you did why can't you
be a grown adult and model what a what a
grown adult conversation would be like
and say to him hey this month is tight
would you mind helping out or I need you
to help out or I'm going to make you
help out but at least do that to his
face instead of just scarfing his stuff
up number one but before all that you
know what would what would I do if I
were in your shoes Justin um it sounds
like you have a fairly close
relationship to her and it sounds like
she has uh she she's off base and so you
need to take her to coffee and say all
right sis here's what's going on you
don't make enough money your job sucks
and you don't work much you need to work
more and you need to get a better job so
you don't have to steal from your own
kid and I'll help you do that I'll coach
you along sis I'll help you get into
Financial Peace University I'll help you
get on a budget I'll help you start
acting like an adult so you're as an
adult not dependent upon a 13-year-old
to quote pay bills you ought to be asham
to yourself putting your family in that
position when you're able-bodied and can
make enough to take care of your family
instead of scarfing from your family and
so that's me and her having a
conversation at coffee but there's
nothing that requires her to do that in
the law and you can't make people do
smart stuff if you could I'd have been
out of business a long time
[Music]
ago
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
Halloween bump music
huh all
right the booth dudes ladies and
gentlemen bringing you what's known as
production
values open phones atle 8825 5225 Laura
Is With Us in West Palm Beach Florida
hey Laura what's
up hi uh I was actually calling because
I'm wondering if there's any benefit in
taking out a student Lo going back to
finish to get my bachelor's degree and
increase the money that I'm making or if
that's a poor decision to take on more
debt I think it's a poor decision to
take on more debt there might be benefit
in going back to school and finding a
way to pay to go back to school but I
don't think that there would be a
benefit in taking out student loans in
order to do so what's your bachelor's
you're
studying uh I was I I took a a break and
I I haven't gone back in years but it
was for communication okay and how's
that going to increase your
income uh I mean most of the jobs that I
see are all they want your bachelors and
it's been very hard to get a job um
which I've managed to do but I'm not
really enjoying it um and it doesn't
really pay a whole
lot listen that that's an absolute
mythology that's just not true okay the
idea that you get a generalized degree
like a communications degree and it
automatically qualif you to make more
money is absolutely not
true okay and you know how I know that
I've got a thousand people working in
this building in a white collar setting
I've got everything from computer
programmers web designers creatives
production people I've got lots of
people in the communications field I
can't tell you a single one off the top
of my head that I pay money to I'm their
boss that I know what their degree
is I don't know if Jade has a degree no
one has ever asked me for my degree ever
ever wow okay so what happened was is
somehow they got into an interview and
convinced us at Ramsay that they could
do the job and then they got in the
building and they actually did the
job the degree was irrelevant the
knowledge to do the job would be
relevant but the actual degree keeping
someone from getting a great paying job
lots of people in this building make
incredible money and I couldn't tell you
a single one of them's degree actually I
take that back I have a
OnStaff counsel that is our our staff
attorney I do know that he has a law
degree yeah that one I do know and I
actually know where his law degree is
from oddly enough but uh but I couldn't
tell you the other lawyers that we've
hired where they went to school even so
um where you went to to school or the
fact that you have a degree in in most
Fields today does not hold you back what
does hold you back is connectivity to
the the subject at hand like what is it
you want to work in do you know enough
about it do you have enough knowledge
base and connectivity to the people in
that building or in that organization
that you want to be a part of that lets
you have a chance and to go prove
yourself but this idea that there's some
kind of vague Veil out there that don't
the people with degrees get behind the
veil yeah it that's old-fashioned
mythology and the last time that was
true was probably 20 years ago what
what's the sort of job that you're
trying to get
Laura um right now I mean I'm a writer
I'm in marketing but I just feel like
you know I make 50k a year now and I
just feel like you know I'm going to be
stuck in this you know in that pay range
I don't feel like there's much unless I
hop are you any
good um are you good at what you do been
doing are you good at it so you are yes
okay yes are you doing something to get
better at
it yes what what are you doing um
getting certifications online actively
researching what's new in the industry
to me that's more valuable that's way
more valuable than going back to
school okay graduates with a degree in
communication that come out or a degree
in journalism that come out that want to
write very seldom make 50k out of the
gate very few of them first first job
out make 50k right
now communications degree and
journalism's degree just don't pay that
much journalism's
worse right it's absolutely horrid I
almost wonder if the better route for
her it sounds like with what she does
there's probably freelance work that she
could do if she wanted to really quickly
raise her income well what I would do is
also start putting some people around
around you that are better than you are
yeah that's true and start meeting with
them and brainstorming and increasing
your skill set in writing and marketing
are you doing copywriting that's one
type of marketing uh or you know writing
ad copy or something that you know
that's a skill that's a unique skill set
that's very valuable yeah because when
you can do that well it creates an
instant Roi for the people you wrote the
ad for and then you be oh she's a studly
copywriter I need her writing this um or
is she writing digital narratives for
marketing campaigns M uh what is it what
is the what is what is it the because
just a a Content person today there's so
much content out there yeah oh yeah and
good quality content delivered in a way
that actually communicates is not a
skill set that you get from a four-year
communications degree it's a skill set
you get from writing a lot with other
highquality world-class writers looking
over your work and questioning you and
measuring the result results of your
work and so I give you an example we're
editing a book of mine right now the old
Total Money Makeover book sold 10
million copies we're working on a the
they haven't done a new issue of it in
like a decade we're going to do a new
issue in the spring so we're going
through the stupid thing with a fine
tooth comb looking at every detail and
every uh uh statistic that's in there
that's outdated right and some of the
examples we have from uh 15 years ago
the home price examples are humorous you
know they're they're hilarious so we're
going through and changing all that so
I'm not personally doing I read through
it this weekend I read through the work
that our writers have done but the
quality of their writing we could tell
by how much correction I sent back wow
you know yeah and so how valuable is
that young guy that's do Nick is doing
that writing in there pretty dead gum
valuable because I didn't find a lot
wrong with his his math was excellent
that's excellent and he he he his
ability to grasp what we were trying to
say and saying it better with in in a
new world modernizing it you know it was
excellent I mean I there's probably uh
800 entries in there or something like
that of changes and and I probably
didn't touch a hundred of them that's
pretty good wow that is pretty good you
know I mean that's that that's exactly
what you learn to do I mean that's
that's your world they don't teach you
how to do that that's what I'm saying if
she were to go back to school what she
learns is already going to be outdated
like she's going to learn more getting
in there like you said getting around
people who are better than her analyzing
people's work that better than hers
former former writer's coffee group that
meets meets for a Bible study or for a a
writer coffee group on Wednesday
mornings before work and Y all sit and
judge each other's writing and up each
other's games yeah and you know like a
songwriters do it in Nashville all the
time oh yeah the number of people that
write a hit song by themselves is
unusual it's very always a group it's
almost always I've got a buddy around
have sat down and I had this hook and he
added this lyric and that Melody shifted
and I've heard that story from
songwriters in Nashville thousands and
thousands of times over the years and
and it's all there was was they good got
in a room and made each other better
yeah or if she starts freelancing
that'll tell her quickly because people
aren't afraid to give you that feedback
or if she's having trouble getting work
that would also indicate all of this is
not to correct you it is to encourage
you you don't need to spend a dime on a
four-year degree I wouldn't I would
spend a ton of effort in getting better
I agree all of you out there the
knowledge current
is what's important knowledge is the
currency that gets you in the door keeps
you in the door and moves you up the
ladder knowledge so how do you move how
do you get in the door move up the
ladder you get more and more knowledge
so you're always adding knowledge you're
always adding tools to your belt the
rest of your life if the last time you
read a non-fiction book was when you
were in school you're
failing you're destined for
mediocrity read a non-fiction book
particularly in your area of expertise
for God's sakes amen you know lean in
learn something new learn something new
hey when I started ramsy they hadn't
invented the internet yet if I had
learned something new most of you 20
million people wouldn't even be out
there right now you have to learn
something new all the time every day
every week every year you got to get
better you're the answer knowledge is
the currency boys and girls not
degrees this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
shot hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need need the
Churchill Mortgage home buyer Edge super
fast pre-approval and a secured interest
rate plus a $5,000 seller guarantee
gives your offer the best chance of
being accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today the Ramsey Show question
of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
neighborly is one place that brings
together a nationwide family of locally
operated providers to help you take care
of repairs routine maintenance or Home
Improvements go to neighbor.com
Ramsey today and start your search all
right today's question comes from Addie
and Oklahoma she says I'm writing
because I have a bit of doubt about this
situation my mom wants to be a co-signer
for me to be able to buy a property
through an FHA loan since I will be an
firsttime home buyer I will be living in
the property but it will be divided and
the other side will be rented I was
pre-approved for
$325,000 my mom and the realtor we are
working with are telling me that we that
we have to put offers on properties at
full asking price but I'm concerned
about this I'm 23 years old I only make
36,000 o I only make $36,000 a year as a
medical assistant and currently owe
$110,000 on student loans should I wait
before I make such a big investment yes
yes yes yes okay let's look at some red
flags here um number one you make
$36,000 $336,000 a year that's quite low
it's half of the national average yeah
that's that's quite quite low and you're
wanting to buy a quarter of a million
dollar house over a quarter of a million
doll house
$325,000 the reason you feel nervous and
the reason that you feel like you can't
breathe because it's literally like John
deloney would say it's your body telling
you there's something wrong and when
there's something wrong don't ignore it
let's look at what's wrong and you can
see what's what the problem is here you
understand that the only way that you're
getting this loan is your mom would be
signing for that means if you can't get
a loan on your own it means that all of
the loan companies know this is a bad
idea you can't pay and the only way that
we mitigate some of this risk is we
bring on someone who we think might be
able to pay pay when you won't be able
to make the payment and in that case
this would be your mother um and she
probably thinks that she's being sweet
for saying oh I'll sign for you I want
you to have this home but that's it's a
horrible idea because you know and I
know that you're not making a lot of
money you still have
debt and the chances of you not being
able to make this payment is high not to
mention there's the renting side about
this it sounds like you are both
dependent on a renter to live on the
other side in order to make this payment
which again is creating a lot of risk
yeah this is a mess Addie don't do it
this is a mess and let's add one more
element to this it's okay you're going
to be a homeowner yeah you're 23 it's
okay you're going to make it okay but
your mom has been controlling this
entire conversation yeah and maybe maybe
it's time that you just said Mom you
know I love you and I'm just not going
to do this right now and that's going to
do a lot of things for you and your mom
one is she's not going to get to control
you with the purchase she and the
realtor are telling you what to do do
you not hear that it was very clear in
the language that you used you're you're
being treated like a little girl like
your mom's pretty she may mean well but
she's Pretty stinking controlling here
and she loves the fact she needs to
cosign
she loves the fact that you are
dependent upon hers CU now she gets to
tell you what to do even more so you
need to break free of Mommy Mommy needs
to be a grown-up and uh Addy needs to be
a grownup yeah because what Happ to be
separated from Mommy and enjoy mommy as
a peer not as a controlling mother of a
23 year-old treating you like she like
you're 133 you're not making a decision
in this entire thing every one of these
decisions are being made by someone else
and pushed upon you mhm you need to
stiff arm this back step back breathe
get you a nice little apartment and a
great life and let all those people go
do their little lives and then when you
get ready to buy a house you'll be in a
position to buy a house yeah cuz only
only two scenarios come of this if she
went through it's bad it's all bad if
she doesn't make that payment a her
mom's lording it over her I it's she her
mom's her mom's going to tell her when
she can take vacation cuz she coasts on
the laan I'm telling you
I smell control freak a mile away and I
and I I've got a good nose for it
Courtney's in Oklahoma City hey Courtney
what's
up hey Dave hey Jade how are you guys
doing better than we deserve what how
can we help um so first of all Jade I'm
a huge fan I've seen your debt free
scream about a hundred times it's it's
fascinating to me awesome it's awesome
it is awesome I um I am I've been
married for 12 years um my husband and I
have three kids we have almost $100,000
in total debt and we're on baby step two
um and when we pay off these small cards
you know that's that's great that's a
great morale booster I would say it's
it's easy um instant satisfaction and we
have some bigger balances that are
coming up that I know are not going to
have that s that instant
gratification um so what I'm asking is
how can I keep morale and encouragement
with my husband and I in between as we
come into these larger balances that we
know are going to take longer and
there's not going to be some instant
gratification there yeah what are what
are the biggest balances that you have
we have two $20,000 cards and one
$20,000 student loan debt okay that's
not as that's not as bad as I thought
you were going to say what's your
income uh we make collectively almost 9
$95,000 a year and um at this point how
much are well like what's your margin
going to the debt snowball every month
we can maybe put an extra 150 he's
working two jobs I'm working jobs did
you say 15 what dollar no girl out of
995,000
yeah you shouldn't have told me that
that's that's not intense that's not
intense at all well no wonder you're
worried about these $20,000 balances
because that's going to take
forever yeah I think it's it's it helps
more when they're the smaller cards
because the smaller cars get paid off
well it helps more because you're not
paying anything on them right you mean
you've got a $150 C that works real good
pay $ 150 but it doesn't work real good
when you got 20,000 you got to put 2,000
not
150 so he's actually active duty
military he's an officer we've had about
almost our entire marriage in active
duty military okay and he's um he
actually did the green to Gold program
so that he could become an officer he
was enlisted that obviously comes with
more income um and he gets PR voted next
week so that's a significant Hy makes 95
now and you're only putting 150 why
where's all your freaking money
going uh debt that I accumulated from my
parents Deb no you have you already told
us the debt okay yeah how much are you
paying on how much are you paying to
your
parents oh I'm not I that's they took
things out in my social security number
well why would you pay it that's called
fraud correct you're correct why would
you pay it you don't need to pay
that file a police report and tell the
police you know where the criminal
is I'm not kidding at all yeah right who
steals from their own kid that's a great
question what's the amount people that
go to jail that's who it is yeah what's
the amount of
that um it wasn't that wasn't very much
but there probably about 10,000 of that
okay so let's just stop a second let me
go back you you Sidetrack me there with
that ridiculous story of your crazy
parents um the but the deal is still
this you got $95,000 coming in that is
not all going to $10,000 worth of debt
that your parents took out in your name
where the flip is all your money
going uh my car payments and other how
much is your car payment uh mine's $700
okay what's the other car payment his is
950 sell the stupid
cars today those are completely
asinine who has
$1,800 worth of car payments and calls
worth of financial trouble I mean you
sell your cars do you see how much
quicker you would pay off your debt if
you had that extra $1,700 freed up
$1,650 freed up you are car
poor have you got a Ford tattoo on your
forehead do they own
you you should get one they own you wow
and a Chevrolet tattoo on the other arm
or whatever ever it is oh my God
9700 we found your problem
courtne it is cars you guys got car
disease they sure do Austin make Tahoe
amputate the Tahoe shoot woo this is a
Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Shir
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Donnie is in St Louis hi
Donnie welcome to the Ramsey Show hi
guys privilege to talk to you guys sorry
I'm a little nervous um I'll give you
the rundown here just in case you need
all this information um okay I'm 40
going to be 47 next month M my wife and
I have recently married we've been
together for three years years we each
have three kids from a previous marriage
so six kids
total um we are both debt-free we are
fully funded emergency fund um well done
right now we are contributing um I'm
only contributing the bare minimum 6% to
my retirement to get the
match because we want to save for a
house um the house we're living in is
from her previous marriage and it has
more problems than you could shake a
stick at um it's probably going to be
one of those Asis sell houses to cut
that short um so when the kids we want
to when the kids are growing gone in
eight years we want to move get get a
house that's ours um why don't you move
before
then huh why don't you move
now well because we don't know if we
would stay in Illinois or if we would go
to Missouri um it just kind of depends
um we have relatives that may or may not
be here at that time also that would I
know
but why would you stay in a house you
hate for eight years well we don't we
don't hate this house we don't hate it
it's got more problems than you can
shake a stick at I thought I heard some
guy say that yeah um if you sold it
would it bring anything or it would just
be a break
even um still ow on it um still about 70
on it what would it bring as is right
now um as not right now it might just
break even okay okay so you would get
out of it and then you would so if you
saved up a down payment in the next year
or so I would move
okay I I don't want to stay in a place
that's not fun for eight
years no not for eight years no I don't
want to do that move into something
that's fun even if it's even if it's
just around the corner and it's just not
broken I agree well I mean we don't
there's there's things that need to be
updated on it like the electrical and
the plumbing and you know I thought you
were going to sell it as
is well I'm that's what I'm saying is
wrong with it it's livable it's not like
you know we don't hate it like we want
to get out tomorrow if we could okay how
can how can we help you like to me um
well the root of my question is um the
reason I put all that in there um so I
just started saving for retirement last
year CU both of us were in previous
relationships that it was you know you
had the the other spouse you were
dragging along trying to do the Dave
plane and they didn't want to do it kind
of thing but luckily we both found each
other and we're both on on board with
the Dave plan okay so um the root of my
question is is for saving for a house I
know you've said if you are going to be
saving for more than five years or more
to do an S&P
500 and I didn't know if I should that's
still the case because of how bad the
market was this past year because the
market was not bad the past year since
January 1 the S&P would have made you n
and a half
per. right that's not bad well I mean my
retirement has been bad this past year
I'm like down
7% I don't know what you're invested in
compared to well it's on Fidelity and
it's also the top uh as far as life
average return and 10 years average
return percentages for small mid
International and large T at 25 I don't
know what your what your mix is that
cause you to lose money in this in this
calendar year okay shouldn't have you
shouldn't have lost money in this
calendar year you should have made money
now you you've lost money since July
it's gone down the Market's down since
July but since January 1 it's up 9 and a
half% okay it was about even all year
until the last couple months last couple
months are horrible down yeah yeah last
couple months it went down yeah um but
yeah that's that's the only thing I've
personally been able to see and I see it
every week because I constantly I get
paid weekly so I keep track of what I
contribute versus how much it's worth
the end of my point is is that you're
making a statement about an absolute
statement about the market that is
absolutely
incorrect because of the because of the
way you're watching it and so based on
that you were getting ready to do the
wrong thing now if you want to leave the
money alone for three or four years the
S&P will be fine if You' left it alone
since January 1 to now you would have
made almost 10% on your money even
though since July the market is down and
so I've got money parked in an S&P and
but I can afford the the up and the down
even if you lost some money it's not the
end of the world in your whole scenario
here uh if so if you want to use the S&P
as long as you can handle it that's fine
but the way you're you the way your
brain's working on the market I'm not
sure you should do it he should just put
it in a high yield savings account and I
want to call out if you're planning to
have this money or save for the next
five or whatever years if you're
planning to do your plan I would not
stay at 6% on your investing for that
long by the way at some point maybe
after a year or two I'd kick it up to
15% and save up for your down payment a
little slower because I don't want you
only doing 6% for the next 5 to eight
years and by the way I just pulled it up
for the fun of it the S&P for the past 5
years is up
53.91 per. there you so that would be
almost 11% a year love it okay for five
years that's the average for five years
so um the last five as of today um so um
you know but since July this year the
market is down sure and because what
we're seeing we're seeing the high
interest rates under the Biden fed uh
that are driving the housing market to a
screeching halt and it's affecting a
whole bunch of other things retailers
are really freaking out about Christmas
they're starting to worry that it's
going to be a really slow Christmas um
interes a lot of people barking about
recession but I don't know we'll see
we're in an election year um coming up
on into an election year so uh we'll see
how this plays out but anyway
all that to say Donnie uh you have a
perception of the market that is based
on last week's paycheck so if that's how
you're going to measure it you should
not put money into an S&P no cuz you
mess around and high savings account and
then get your baby step four back up to
15% as Jade said um because you're not
doing this short term you don't want to
be out of 15% in baby step 4 for longer
than two and a half three years and what
you're describing here is eight years
and so you need to be fully invested in
your uh in into good mutual funds in
your retirement do you think he was
trying to save up and pay full out cash
for a house I don't know cuz I'm like an
eight-year plan that's a aggressive I
don't know um they've done really well
uh but the that old house represents a
bunch of stuff I don't like personally
Ruth is in mon Georgia hi Ruth how can
we
help hi Dave hi Jade um the reason I'm
calling in is because my husband and I
have been on baby step two um not as
intense as we should have been we're
kind of starting to pick it up but I'm
do with a baby in six weeks and y'all
always said to you know when you get to
that point pump the brakes and just save
up yeah so that's what we're doing now
um but you know come January after she's
born barring any complications we'll
start back intense again um no intense
for the first time well yeah intense for
the first time okay we we still had a
reduction this year it just wasn't way
it should have been yeah that's not
intense yeah anyway so um my question is
I owe about 22,000 left on my car um so
it's at about the point where I could
trade it in for about 25 right now or
sell it for around 30 um or by the time
we played off paid off and if we stick
to the snowball schedule I ran all the
numbers multiple times and it always
comes out to April 2025 sell it yeah
sell it and buy a $7,000 car yeah yeah
cuz we's at the point where it's like
you know we want something that's
dependable $7,000 $7,000 cars are
Dependable what about your husband's
car um he has a truck but it's almost
paid off um I want something that's
dependable as code for I don't like the
car all these cars are Dependable $7,000
cars are Dependable there's nothing
wrong with $7,000 car if you pick the
right car you have it checked out
mechanically you don't buy a piece of
junk and you know because you just look
like the way looked or something but I
mean actually check out the mechanical
background there's lots of really good
cars for 7 Grand really nice cars and so
yeah I I would sell that puppy and be
out of debt there's no way I'm fighting
with this stupid vehicle for three years
no way no chance no fun at all in that
scenario Ruth so yeah baby comes I'd be
selling that car and uh don't you ever
say I need something Dependable again
it's just not true this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America open phones
at
5225 Michelle and Tyler are with us in
Las Vegas hey guys how are you good how
are you better than we deserve what's up
in your
world uh well I am calling in to get
your advice uh um my hus my husband and
I um bought a house a couple of years
ago and um I am in the mortgage industry
and
um yeah I'm a mortgage laan officer and
I was earning about eight times what I'm
earning today um back in in 2001 uh 2021
when we bought we bought the home and
then the crash happened a few months
later yeah so we've gone we're at a
negative um 12 Grand a month in our from
our expenses versus our uh income and
I've kept a year-to-date tally um since
January of this year to current um and
so those are exact numbers and we are at
an interest rate of 2.625 on our
mortgage so really good rate um and we
have um we have about $400,000 in stock
and we have about a million and a half
in re reement which we don't want to
touch and we have um minimal in in
savings and checking you know maybe 30
grand and so um we have borrowed about a
100,000 from my parents um and is that
how you're floating the 12K month loss
um that was to help and also make sure
that we were able to pay on our um
insurance premiums that were due in
April of this year we have
um uh we have just to keep on our
savings plan of that as well as keep up
you know help keep afloat and we ended
up getting a car loan which we we don't
ever we normally don't have car loans
but we ended up financing a car loan at
5.24% why would you buy a car when your
income was off
70% because um our uh car was the lease
was up and the payment was quite High
five and so we were and we also okay
what is your what's your home
worth uh three and a half million okay
what does Tyler make Tyler what do you
make um he 300
300 well his exact monthly income the
net is
3,948 okay and and you guys where is all
of your money going then because you're
how you owe what on the
house uh
two two
2,164 so what is your house
payment um
11,400 and that he's bringing home
30,000 so why are you burning 12 where's
it all
going um it is going
to
private uh what's
tuition if 40
300 a
month yes okay where's the rest of
it um savings with our our insurance
premium grocery 2200 a month savings so
you're having a super expensive whole
life
plan right that was started um nine
years ago and our 10th payment which
it's a 10 pay was due in April so we
don't have to pay that yeah you can
cancel that and you should it's a piece
of crap to start with but um and that
that stinking things what 5,000 bucks or
something it's 5416 a month you do so
you're borrowing money from your parents
to pay a whole life
plan is $6,000 of your 12
burn that's an easy fix go get some term
insurance and drop that garbage cash the
cash value out and pay your mom and dad
back how much cash value have you got
so we have 400,000 cash value on that
and you have 400,000 in stock
also yes yeah cash that crap out there
you go why are you you've got these
assets turn around borrow from your
parents why not use the
assets
well agreed um we have a loan already of
185,000 on there okay so you're only
going to net 200 that's fine you can
still clear no that's an addition the
400 is an addition to that um
and that if I borrow against it then if
you cancel it you're going to walk out
with all the money and get rid of the
expense and it is a horrid investment
this is what's killing you that you have
two major symptoms in these numbers your
loss of income and this horrendous
investment
program well the 12 Nega the third
symptom is is you've not cut your
lifestyle because you're used to living
on $7 $800,000 a year and y'all are
still acting like that
agreed um and I
don't I
am I want a I I put together a budget I
I um I it's just having them the family
follow it so are you GNA are you going
to do what Dave just suggested are you
going to cancel this whole life and are
you going to clear out those stocks and
are you going to pay back that loan to
your parents before we go further I just
want to know if you're going to do that
well if that's what you're suggesting
that I do then that's why I'm calling in
for advice um I'm suggesting you to stop
all Whole Life policies immediately
they're a crummy place to put money to
start with if everything was healthy I
would suggest that I sure as crud
wouldn't be borrowing from my parents to
pay a whole life premium which is if
essentially what you've done here um and
I sure as crud wouldn't have bought a
car when I'm so broke I can't pay my
bills on payments I would have bought a
car I could pay cash for I would have
cashed out enough stock and go buy a car
mhm
you don't need more payments you've got
problems so you're you're increasing
your burn rate every time you do that
not decreasing it to turn the corner so
what you do in these situations is you
button down the hatches the hurricane is
here the hurricane is temporary we don't
know how long it's going to be on Shore
but right now we've got 60 and 80 mph
wind coming at our house and and whether
it's here for another year or whether
it's here for another 6 months you and I
don't know I pray God your income comes
back next spring because that means the
real estate market has started to come
back and this ridiculous economy were
sitting in with these interest rates has
started to reverse and go the other
direction I hope that for America and it
certainly would be great for Michelle
and Tyler so but I don't know how long
the Hurricane's going to last but right
now you've got a burn rate that you can
fix you do not have to have a burn rate
cut your freaking lifestyle get rid of
the whole life policy get rid of the car
payment cash out enough stock to do that
and get your look at your family and go
boys and girls we don't get to live like
we used to live we don't have the
money and you and your husband be
grown-ups and sit down and go we have to
live on less than we make we have a
Brave New World we're in we don't make
700,000 we only make 360
now wow and we're going to have to
figure out a way to make it on that for
a little while your house is not your
problem your house is great I'd sit
right tight in your house but I'd cut a
whole bunch of other stuff out of your
life now right now and get rid of this
burn rate and then you can wait and when
it comes back up you can have some
enjoyment stuff again in the meantime
you guys need to find beans and rice
back in your budget again this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
sh
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade washaw remsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
88255 225 Kean Is With Us in Atlanta hi
Kean how are you I'm good how you doing
better than I deserve what's
up well just yesterday my father asked
me to help him buy a house um mind you
my father's 61 I live with him um and I
are you really I am
whoa yeah
why are you living with your
dad well right now at this moment well
during Co um I found a mentor who taught
me skill digital marketing online and I
managed to turn it into a career I make
$86,000 and I sat down with my parents
when it's first when I first got my
first job told them my ambitions and
what I wanted to do and they were
finally me just staying home as long as
I paid uh the light bill and when they
said yes I was like it's three years ago
what do you make I make $86,000 why are
you living at home you make
$86,000 I plan on moving out this year
good like yesterday yeah yeah you make
$86,000 I know go have a life so what's
this got to do with now you live on your
own and you're 22 and you have a career
making
$86,000 because we just moved you out
now we've got that settled now your dad
wants you your help buying a house but
you don't live there so why does he want
your help buying a house cuz he can't
buy it on his own
no my dad
um my dad all his wife they've been
living Check to Check he's like he's um
just for give you more context his event
is like $600 but he pids $1,000 in car
payment he pays $1,000 in car payments
yes between two cars that that's why
he's living paycheck to paycheck okay
keep
going
and um so
with all that and the things that he's
told me in passing I feel like what he
wants to do would actually hurt him yeah
more so I agree and it's just I don't
know how to from from the financial
things and things that I've learned
consuming you know your content and
other content sh I feel like home
ownership is like not like a like a real
thing currently for him corre I don't
know how to well if he's asking you he's
not asking you for financial advice he's
asking you to sign on the line to help
him get a deal now let's change this
okay let's talk about this for a second
cuz there's two
different emotional situations with your
dad emotional situation number one is
you live there emotional Situation
Number Two is you don't live there which
is what I'm recommending yeah because
once you move out the obligation that
you feel you don't have any obligation
then it goes away then you're sitting
down with your dad and going dad I love
you um but I I I can't parti participate
in you buying a home because I love you
I think you're going to bring harm to
yourself until you get your financials
cleaned up and I can show you some of
the stuff I'm learning if you want me to
if you don't want me to and it'll help
you get your house but if you don't want
me to I understand and but I can't help
I can't participate in you buying a
house because I think it's going to
bring you harm and I love you and I
don't want to bring you
harm okay that's a lot harder to say
when you live there mhm hey is he going
to be pissed when you tell him that you
don't want to sign oh yeah for the loan
definitely I don't I personally don't
think he's very prideful I don't think
he's gonna be pissed at all like from
what he's told me that he has saved like
from all the years he worked he's I he I
know for a fact he doesn't have the cash
for a down payment yeah and I'm afraid
that he's gonna make a stupid decision
and pull from his retirement yeah and he
he might and he's well and he's got a
he's got a car payment that needs to be
get he needs to get rid of that he needs
to build an emergency fund he needs to
save a down payment whether you're 26 or
whether you're 66 those same things
apply and that's what I would tell him
and I'm almost his age I'm actually
older than him so um you know I would
say young
man well the thing you have to accept is
even if you frame it the way Dave so
eloquently put it even if you come to
him you say all those things he still
might go and do something stupid and
it's likely with the way he's been
living his life and his it's likely that
he will continue on that same path and
if he doesn't you've just got to and
hear this it's not your fault no his
behavior is not because of
you okay okay you you helping him do
something stupid or him doing something
stupid on his
own is that you know he does something
stupid on his own is not your fault you
helping him do something stupid that's
bad for him is your fault and you've
identified that you know what that is
but it's very difficult for for you to
tell your dad who is 40 years older than
you no mhm it's emotionally hard to do
that it's doubly hard to do that when
you live there right dude when you move
out in your proximity to all this
changes you'll be shocked at how little
you think about this but right now it's
right under yourse you know how he it
changes the level of obligation yeah you
have an obligation an emotional
obligation toxic though it be to help
your dad okay you have a a double
obligation to help your dad if you live
in his house right you follow
me both of those obligations do not bind
you to doing something that harms him
and we're all three in agreement that
this is harmful to
him yeah buying a house when you're
broke Kean is not good for you
it causes you to get broker that's why
we call them
Brokers That's it man I mean you've
heard me say that a thousand times and
so I want your dad to get a house but I
don't want his house to get him and I
sure as crud don't want it to get him
and his newly successful young
son I'm so proud of where you are and I
don't want you to get chopped down as
you're in a growth spurt
yeah this is going to chop you down
young man don't let it do that and and
your dad doesn't mean to do that but he
doesn't know any different and he's just
flailing around and he thinks buying a
house is going to make everything better
and it's not it's going to make
everything worse for him and if you get
involved it's going to make everything
worse for you and you want a roll you
need to rock and roll and go get you a
place like this
week this week man go get you an
apartment this week and set you up a
life and get yourself strong and then if
you've got a big old huge pile of money
and you got a million dollars and your
dad is 82 and he never changed his ways
and he's still broke and he can't buy
groceries you can afford to buy him
groceries Dave I feel like there's been
a theme all three hours of parents
parents just messing up it's parents
stealing money from their kids it's
parents taking out Credit in their kids'
names it's parents wanting them to coign
whether I co-sign on that loan with you
or the kids co-signing on the loan with
them it's just parents parents
misbehaving parents yeah so if you guys
want to label this particular episode
for YouTube It's called misbehaving
parents what happens when parents
misbehave well let me tell you you screw
your kids you do that's what happens
when parents misbehave and they put they
have to go your job in life should be to
do the opposite of screw your own
kids it's just it's sad the energy that
they have to put in
to unravel all of this whether it's
having to call credit card agencies or
you know call the bank or call the
police and say no it wasn't me that
spent the money it was my dad or no it
was my mom it's unfair a criminal stole
because stealing someone's identity is
frauda it's a federal fraud if you do it
with credit cards it's fraud and if it
was anyone else criminal fraud it's a
crook if someone does it in Russia and
they steal your identity we go oh the
Russian mafia is a bunch of crooks if
your own dad does it you go well I'm
paying it back cuz my daddy stole my
identity no your dad is a freaking
criminal he's a crook you need to file a
police report on it a't that crazy how
we'll let our own family treat us and
you wouldn't i' dare ever let somebody
on the street treat you that way okay I
know that's right it was anyone else
behaving parents misbehaving parents
misbehaving parents and some with just
out andout malice mhm yep and it causes
the kids to question their she's sold is
lawnmower I can't even get my head
around that I know her 13-year-old I
know
wow this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
oh
[Music]
Jade Wasa Ramsey personality open phones
atle
5225 Caleb is with us in Indianapolis hi
Caleb welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey D and Jade how are you better
than we deserve what's
up U so I'm 23 and I just got married a
month ago and uh my
building a plan thank you um we would be
on baby step 4 to six but I'm trying to
decide how do we best invest as a new
married
couple well as a new married couple if
you're on baby step four five and six
then you would just work the plan as it
is so you would invest 15% of your
income of your household household
income so we're currently investing 10
to 11 in our separate R our rths through
our jobs um and then we have extra money
on top of that that we could build that
up to 15% or start putting towards a
house fund we don't own a home yet I'm
trying to decide is it best to put that
towards a house or with the volatility
of the market right now store that away
in stocks and bonds you could I mean you
could definitely do them both at the
same time if you're like hey I want to
invest 11% and put you know what x
amount towards the down payment you
could do that for a little while I
wouldn't do that longterm how long do
you think it would s take you to save up
uh a reasonable down payment house MH um
so we actually have a lump sum on top of
our 3 to six months that we could either
put towards the house right now or throw
into uh different savings accounts
what's the lump
sum we have $35,000 on top of our 3 to
six month of uh that's actually a
six-month emergency fund with a
two-month working capital fund yeah way
to go you've done a great job yeah I I
don't have any problem with you
continuing to build some cash for a
little while but probably in the next uh
12 months to 24 months you're going to
buy a house MH and so let's pile stack
stack cash until then on top of that 35
put down a good strong down payment in
18 to 24 months M and uh then then kick
your baby step four up because you'll be
done with baby step 3B which is what we
call saving for a down payment on house
if you didn't know and um then uh then
that sets you up for you know back up to
or then you would get up to 15% of your
income going to retirement at that point
so did you say that you have Roth 401ks
is that what I heard yes yeah so I split
mine between a pre-tax and post tax
account um whereas she puts all her in a
pre-tax fund I would put it all in post
tax Roth IRA yeah you have Roth
available or post
tax uh the Roth uh 401K yeah if it's
Roth you need to you need to do all Roth
so after you guys both Max those out are
you saying that there's still money left
yeah he's saying 11% is going in there
and he's saying currently putting about
1,500 a month into our different
retirement accounts and then based on
our current budget we are storing away
an extra 2500 a month on average yeah
good for you put that towards the house
that's another 30,000 bucks in a year
M so that put you 65,000 down payment a
year from
now if we were to split it would you
recomend throwing it into the mutual
funds that you guys discussed put that
into like some sort of bond ladder
neither I wouldn't do either one I just
go high yield savings because you're
going to do it in about 12
months okay you get a high yield savings
because we're not trying to make a bunch
of money on this the money that's going
to be in this account is coming from
your pocket not from
interest okay okay mean the amount of
Interest physical interest that you
let's say you make 10% on 60,000 you
made 6,000 if you make 5% on 60,000 you
make
3,000 neither one of those numbers
causes you to buy a house the number is
655,000 because you put 65,000 in there
not because the bank added three or six
you follow me okay so your rate of
return in a short period of time like a
12-month window is almost
irrelevant okay mathematically speaking
you know and so you can get caught up on
oh a bond ladder or you know a series of
H or do I do do the do the S&P it
doesn't matter I mean it doesn't matter
cuz it's you're not in there long enough
for it to matter that's right cuz again
12 months from now you're going to be
sitting on 65 70,000 bucks with a down
payment and you're going to buy a home
on a 15-year fix where the payments no
more than a fourth year take home pay
dude you're in charge that's awesome I
love it and then he's going to be
putting his whole 15% to his Roth 401ks
love it it's great yeah and if if those
are Max then you can go over to regular
personal roths in mutual funds still get
to 15% once get the house purchased
Bellamy is in Washington hi Bellamy how
are
you good how are you better than I
deserve what's
up um I had a
vehicle and it's now I can't my mom
can't afford it anymore and so I'm going
to buy my first vehicle and I'm going to
keep this vehicle
for five to seven years and so I didn't
know what a good applicable down down
payment or amount that I should have how
old are you I'm 20 years old okay and I
currently in college but I have no
student loan debt all my family wanted
me to get a loan for the last 3K this
year but I said no and I'm paying for it
myself great I'm proud of you good work
do you have any money at all for a
car um I told my mom that I needed till
December because my last school payment
is in November and it's a last bit is
going to be
$1,000 um so I told her I needed tell um
December to start saving and then I told
her the latest I would be would probably
be February because I have to start
after that saving 10 grand and can she
let you drive this car until
then she said that she would um said
that would be okay okay so by February
how much money will you have to buy a
car I am hoping to have at least five
grand good buy a car for
5,000 okay so I shouldn't do a Lo or
anything no last thing you need is a car
payment you're
broke yeah I mean you got you're barely
nipping and tucking and getting this
doing double back flips and twists and
everything else and getting this tuition
covered I'm proud of you add add a car
payment to it you might not be able to
make
that well this is the last payment in
November and I'll be completely student
loan debt free and then I want to and
then I have a little bit of a gap until
next October until nursing school and so
that's when I wanted to kind of build
that 10 grand yeah good and so we don't
need a car payment we need to build 10
grand yes the car payment gets in your
way of doing anything you want to do in
this life so get you an inexpensive
$5,000 car or however much money you
have by February if you got more you
spend it all on a car I don't care but
um now let me ask you this your mom has
done this car deal where's your
dad my dad lives up in um Belle
Washington does he know do you have a
good relationship with
him I really U we're we're good like I
guess we're friends I gu okay does he
does he know anything about vehicles at
all um yeah okay maybe he can help you
or someone else can help you but what
what I would suggest what I would
suggest you do is you look for a car
that is not
pretty okay but it is very reliable and
has low
miles and has a lot of life left in it
so I don't care about the sex appeal of
this vehicle as a matter of fact it
might be the kind of vehicle you need to
give a name to Old
Blue big red mhm Bera I don't know let's
give this car a name
but it's it's it's the dinosaur it's the
thing that's reliable and everybody kind
of Snickers about the way it looks cuz
Bellamy you ain't picking up boys with
this car you're living life I have a I
have a boyfriend and we remod an RV so I
don't have any rent at the say I just
have to pay $400 for a spot and we're 20
and
21 okay well so my my point though is
that you you need to get a car that's
reliable and that you don't care what
people think that was my point okay and
I'm sorry that was funny what we're
after so she doesn't have to worry about
getting Boys in this car cuz she's
already got somebody I know I already
got that covered Dave Dave you kind of I
think I I think I missed that I lost
that one okay this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
our scripture of the day Ephesians 2:10
for we are God's handiwork created in
Christ Jesus to do good works which God
prepared in advance for us to do kimens
Wilson said every once in a while a new
technology an old problem and a big idea
turn into an innovation
kimn Wilson by the way founder of
holiday in open phones at
88255 225 Robert is in Atlanta Georgia
hi Robert welcome to the Ramsey Show
hello Dave how are you doing thank you
for everything you
do got through to speak to you uh I read
your books recently A friend of mine uh
put up put put them on in the g i Reddit
thank you uh and I'm a retired military
guy and just recently retired 26 years
United States military Air Force Marines
and navy a little bit too thanks for
your
service and I've been trying to kind of
figure out where do I stand in your kind
of the baby steps so to speak because
I've been doing things as a military
kind of guy a little bit out of Step so
to speak because of the fact that we
moved so much and you know couldn't buy
a house and all those kind of things so
as of now I'm like you know my kids
graduated from college both of them
great uh both of them took on a little
bit of student loan so what you said not
to do so I'm trying to help them through
that you know they're kind of trying to
find a way to work now I have some debt
but I'm in my second job now I have
pensions my wife is also a retired
military person too so she has a pension
too as well and she's working too and
her her her dream job her second
retirement job and I just don't know
where I how to deal with you know
working debt and where I stand in as far
as which I to be applying to baby step
wise so you stand uh just where
everybody else stands the only thing is
you have four sources of income going
into your budget two military
retirements thank you for your service
both of you and two jobs all going into
all going on the top line of your budget
that total dollar amount is your monthly
budget and then you apply that monthly
budget to living and making progress on
the baby steps how much debt do you
have uh 40K in car for me another white
50k in a car just bought a house for
500k uh and I got about 45 5K in credit
cards what's your household
income uh I've got well I've got 300
plus in tsp no household income oh
household income what's your two re
what's your two retirements and your two
jobs add up
to uh including my pension my disability
and stuff about
310k great all that's all four that's
two jobs you and your wife and you and
your wife's income yep that's her job my
job my uh retirement which I get now her
retirement and uh my disabilities and
she gets retirement right yeah she get
she she gets hers in about three years
so her oh so she doesn't have she
doesn't have military retirement coming
in yet okay so you got a $310,000 income
and you got $150,000 in debt yep what
would happen if you lived on 150 of that
and paid the rest off in debt a
year what was that question again what
would happen out of that $310,000 income
what if you decided you know what we're
going to live on $150,000 which by the
way is more than double the median
average income what if you decide you're
going to live on 150 and take the rest
of it and pay off your debt and be debt
free in 12 months that's what my goal is
I've kind of got one of those apps and
look at your kind of every like what
your budget app is to try to say just
pay my de this I can L off my pension
right now period and just use my working
money cuz my working money is like 200k
of my job I'm a physician okay I paid
off 250 of medical debt I mean for my
student loan so thing is like should I
be using my working money just to pay
you should be using every dollar you can
squeeze out of your budget to pay off
your three debts your two cars and your
credit card debt and you cut up your
credit cards now you don't have any
payments but a house payment you make
310 that's pretty sweet and now we're in
a position to build an emergency fund of
3 to 6 months of expenses baby step
three baby step four is is 15% of your
income going into retirement and so
we're going to add to your retirement
income by creating an actual NES TIG not
just a pension a pension is fine but it
dies with you and so um so you need in
addition to having a pension you need to
build a nest deck and the great news is
you make a lot of money and so you
should be able to build a substantial
Nest deck build some wealth man become
wealthy now since he has that pension
would you still have him invest 15% yep
absolutely 15% until we get the house
paid off when the house is paid off we
don't have to worry about the kids
they're done baby step five is X through
it and then uh baby step then get the
house paid off when the house is paid
off we just build a big old pile of
wealth and create a big old pile of
generosity and a big old pile of
enjoyment and all of that that's what
this is for so again thanks thanks for
your service guys you've done a great
job now let's clean this mess up Cindy
is in Cincinnati hi Cindy how are you hi
I'm doing good Dave how how are you
better than I deserve what's
up well um I'm 66 years old and um I
owned three houses I went to a divorce a
few years back and um sorry um anyway I
ended up with three houses actually
ended up with two houses and um uh I
continued working and my son lives in
one house and and he has four kids
single dad and I rent that to him and
let him take care of that house um so
then I ended up moving out of the house
that I was in and bought my neighbor's
house right next door because it looked
more of a retirement home that I wanted
to be in and I had been fixing up the
other house uh but I kind of got into
the Airbnb business to bring in some
income while I was fixing that up and to
help you know do some Renovations MH so
um I make about 50,000 a year off the
Airbnb and my job my day do my day job
that uh I'm at is at risk right now I'm
afraid we're probably going to file
bankruptcy what do you make there um
about uh 98,000 what do you do so uh I'm
in purchasing okay all right among other
things I'm the Jack of all trades there
yeah last man last man
standing yeah that's hard I've been
there 32 years so um wow been there a
long time and I've got a GED so I'm
blessed that I have what I have so how
old are you 66
66 yeah so uh what's your
question well um if we file bankruptcy I
owe 270,000 uh on two of the houses and
I'm thinking about taking my 401 part of
my 401 and paying everything off how
much is in the how much is in the
700,000 I
would so the other thing is I could but
I I rent the Airbnb and if I keep that
house I could sell that house you can if
you'd rather have the four would you
rather 401k or the
house um the house doesn't mean that
much it's just it's got a good income of
about three to 4,000 a month which one
would you rather have I don't care but
if you're going to keep the house pay
them
off well I can't keep the house I well I
pay them off as I you know as I
the income that I come off of the Airbnb
yeah pay them off I mean I'm paying that
down yes you asked if you should take
the money out of the 401K if you get
laid off and pay them off yes you should
okay because you still got plenty of
money in the 401K and you got three paid
four houses the only thing that's left
hanging in the air is I have this
sinking feeling that you're really not
charging your son much rent at all like
$50 or something
stupid so when is your son going to
create a sustainable life for
himself uh I asked him that every time
well every time every time you don't
make
him yeah okay yeah he is definitely
um it's a sore subject for sure yep yep
and uh it's that's costing you more than
this all everything else we're talking
about put together because you got a big
old pile of money tied up over there and
got zero return on it except what it's
going up in value while he lives there
and probably doesn't even do the
maintenance
well he does do the maintenance and he
does help me on mine so there is some
pluses to have him there but I've got
four grandkids so you know I could ask
him to move but I you know I choose to
uh not just so they have a place to live
darling they'll have a place to
live you're not making your grandbabies
homeless by making your son be
responsible yeah that's just not true
don't tell yourself a lie that's not
true it's it it is it's time for him to
move up the ladder in his life I'm
worried about him right now I kind of
think he uh he he needs a little bit of
a callous or two mhm just just listening
in just listening in and loving you hey
thanks for calling in that puts us hour
the Ramsey Show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
a